before Stephen twitch boss's tragic
death he and wife Alison holker were
planning their next chapter she has the
vision so once it comes together I'm
like yeah you know what you were right
as reported in deadline the couple had
multiple TV projects in the works with
HGTV and having your own show it's about
the brand and many of them at HGTV
when it comes to the couple's various
projects HGTV says they're taking the
time to consider different scenarios
but for now the network is focused on
quote wishing our best to Allison and
the entire Boss family during this
difficult time last year Allison hosted
hgtv's competition series Design Star
next gen the more engaging every second
is the better
twitch shared his excitement with ET
stopping by as again
what I loved about it though is that
like none of the challenges seemed
frivolous for anything you know
everything kind of really fed into it's
like who is going to be the next HGTV
star and every episode every week kind
of really pushed the artist and also the
audience closer together to know their
own personal brand which I thought was
really smart on the couple's development
slate was living the dream a series that
would help first-time buyers find a home
another project a show chronicling the
couple as they managed construction of a
full-sized Malibu Barbie Dream House
HGTV had already found a home to get the
makeover and filming was set to start in
January elsewhere twitch and Allison
were reportedly exploring a potential
variety show dance competition and a
game show we just kind of GrooVe and it
just comes it comes together
speak of twitch's death each
his tremendous loss I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world Allison's
yet to speak out Following last week's
statement where she called twitch the
backbone of their family and reflected
on his legacy Allison wrote Steven lit
up every room he stepped into he valued
family friends and Community above all
else I am certain there won't be a day
that goes by that we won't honor his
memory
thank you